my dear Juliet why are you still so
beautiful powerful performance so I die
with the kiss so what they're saying it
was a peanut allergy I don't even get
how it happened
she was so vigilant about it hello who's
there Lance
rumor has it this totally opens up the
scholarship yeah Jordan was assumed you
mean the whole world patron thing oh
it's sweet deal I mean full books and
board everything they did manage to get
a copy of the world patron scholarship
finalists so after Jordan Brittany's
nexts speaking up the scholarship don't
you think it's a little more than
coincidental that most of the people on
it or Ted never said it was funny maybe
it's just about too much kind of dude
wait a minute what was the last thing
that touched his lips Angela's lips
voila
positive for peanut residue who the hell
did this anybody there
I'm pretty sure somebody's following me
who's following you really this is just
too creepy nobody's asking any questions
nobody's doing anything this is not a
game Samantha this is as serious as it
gets
he needs that scholarship more than
anyone else and what's scariest I'm the
last one in line for the scholarship he
gets rid of me she's got it
you
you